Kevin Hart what the fit this is a great
idea cuz you're a very fit guy you take
physical fitness very seriously yes a
very funny guy and I had a blast I know
a lot of people were doing it with you I
did an episode and it was so much fun to
do it with you and it was a workout at
the same time it was I mean look I
wanted to find a way to mix fun and
physical fitness and you know make a
show out of it I think yeah within the
creative that goes along with what the
fit it was about taking my friends and
putting my friends and situations that
they wouldn't expect to see themselves
in and finding a way to work out within
the creative situation yeah as you know
because you did the show it was very
very it was it was good it was done well
and more importantly we we found a new
side of physical fitness I mean me and
you we sumo much we sumo wrestle yeah
Kevin and I and we got in the full getup
and we suma wrestled real sumo wrestlers
for real for real and a lot of laughs I
thought there was a lot of really funny
stuff that we got into a lot of them
were at your body remember when you
first well you first took your shirt
about out of time well that's that's
something out of time he took his shirt
off we were like wow really we don't
have any time wow that's what it looks
like huh
that's where a lot of the labs came in
and then and and and we there was one
remember we took a break because we were
laughing so hard we said we gotta we
gotta get back to work
this isn't about laughing it koenings
chest you know let's get that worked
then we got it I remember that was funny
when you first took your shirt off we
got ours I I was laughing I was laughing
so that was that may have been funnier
than me getting stopped at the Super
Bowl
just because the same thing happened
when he walked out we're like whoa whoa
whoa we don't know if we can put this
little TV you and your yeah your
entourage did look shot yeah we were
definitely shot but it was so it was so
white okay like I've seen I've seen
versions of like like pale but this you
shall take off your shirt
oh they give you every time to be okay
oh god it's a sad sad that this is your
last appearance oh I love you I love you
and just know that I will never see you
again we're going to show a clip of this
now my producer is so mad at me right
now because we're just we're not they
always tell me like you got this much
time you got time when you're on I don't
[Laughter]
yeah our show went over like four hours
ago we have a clip here Kevin Hart what
the fit sumo wrestling take a look at
somebody with that money Mayweather
style
okay
[Music]
so though that was very good that's how
you did great
I had no problem with that I feel to get
you ass
[Applause]
you